hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
Joseph Butler at the beginning of his
sermon number eight is going to open up
a problem which is fairly specific but
could actually be looked at as part of a
much larger
theological philosophical problem
traditionally we call this the problem
of evil saying you know if there is a
God and God is all-knowing and
all-powerful and benevolent why is there
evil in the world and he's particularly
interested in the question of anger why
did God give us anger and he also tells
us that listen I'm not going to get into
the much larger problem let's just
confine ourselves to this so how can we
frame this he begins by saying since
perfect goodness in the deity is the
principle from whence the universe was
brought into being and by which it is
preserved so we've got God is perfectly
good right
out of that goodness he produced the
entire universe and sustains it in its
being so presumably he knows what's
going on if we go on a little bit
further and he says general benevolence
is the Great Law of the whole moral
creation so this is adding one more
additional thing to it you know there's
sort of built into the fabric of
creation itself General benevolence
which is willing good and doing good to
other beings
so he says it's a question which
immediately occurs then
why had man implanted in him a principle
which appears the direct contrary to
benevolence so why would we have anger
which seems to go against General
benevolence how does anger do so well
because when you're angry you actually
try to do some sort of punishment or
harm or injury whatever it's going to be
to some other being the being that has
angered you so how does this actually
fit in and you could say well you know
human beings imperfect Creations kind of
screwed up and that doesn't really work
with getting God off the hook if you've
got a powerful enough God I mean if
you're talking about say the ancient
Greek gods you could even be like
Epictetus the stoic and say you know if
you're going to complain about God about
how screwed up we are then realize that
God made us out of imperfect stuff and
he made us as good as we could be
it doesn't work for the god of
Christianity and you know Butler who is
himself a bishop knows that quite well
so he has to give some sort of reasoning
or argument about why why we have anger
how does this actually fit into the
divine plan and the Divine goodness and
so he says the foot upon which inquiries
of this kind should be treated as this
to take human nature as it is and the
circumstances in which it is placed as
they are and then consider the
correspondence between that nature and
those circumstances or what course of
actions and behavior respecting those
circumstances any particular affection
or passion leads us to now it would be
very easy to be a little bit mistaken or
misled when you hear that take human
nature as it is and be like yeah humans
are screwed up they're awful you know
just look at these you know brute
creatures and how easily they get angry
at each other
Butler actually has in mind when he says
taking human nature as it is human
nature in a sort of abstract how it
ought to be kind of sense not just the
you know human nature as we experience
it here a little bit later he will tell
us um that he's he's not talking about
people who are vicious or those who are
you know actually on the other side he
wants to talk about the general course
of resentment considered as a natural
passion neither increased by Indulgence
nor corrected by virtue nor prevailed
over by other passions or particular
habits of life so how do we take an
ordinary human being who's neither
particularly good nor particularly bad
so how far Human Nature has a respect to
circumstances that's the way that he
frames it that could be a little bit
confused using but what we're looking at
is well what are we human what are we
human beings like and then how does
anger work in particular situations
so he begins by saying
God's not going to give us a passion or
an emotion that is by itself or in
itself evil he's just not going to do
that and we can think of all sorts of
other things I mean compare this to our
appetite for food or our desire for sex
they're not bad in themselves they get
bad when we misuse them or as he's going
to say abuse right so it's very
dependent on our use our use can go
wrong so with anger that's something
that can happen to us quite easily and
he says you know what we need to figure
out here is is what the proper use or
function or purpose of anger is now he
divides anger into two types sudden or
Hasty anger and deliberate or settled
anger sometimes he calls the second one
resentment the first one is sort of just
a automatic reaction that we have in
many cases he talks about it as being
instinctual sort of like if something is
coming towards your eye you turn your
eye away or you close your eye right
there's a lot of cases where we
encounter resistance or opposition as he
calls it or threats or violence or you
know harm or or you know not injury as
such because he reserves the word injury
for something that's deliberately done
and we react against it right and so
what is the purpose of hasty and sudden
anger well he tells us that it's
actually
self-defense I mean he goes into a
little bit uh more discussion of it he
says that the reason and end for which
human beings were made liable to this
passion why we can actually have this is
that we may be better qualified to do
and he talks about three things prevent
resist defeat sudden Force violence and
opposition considered merely as such not
not in a moral sense not attributing
motives to the other person it's
basically just to you know protect our
ourselves and maybe we also do so with
other people maybe we get angry and we
run in and save the child from the
burning building or something like that
he doesn't go into that and he does say
that it's for self-defense not for the
administration of justice a little bit
later he'll say that you know sudden
anger is raised by and is intended to
prevent a remedy mere harm distinct from
injury it can also be raised by what he
calls injury but that's that's a whole
different topic so that one's pretty
easy to understand God gives us or
implants within us these instincts that
lead us to protect ourselves and if we
didn't have that
we'd be badly off right we would be
swamped by the problems that we we run
into
what about deliberate anger okay this
requires a lot more discussion and
examination he tells us that deliberate
anger as such is concerned with are
conceptions of virtue and vice of moral
good and evil those are the words that
he actually uses he says that
um
let us reflect on the manner in which
we're touched with reading for example a
feign story of baseness and villainy
worked up to move our passions it raises
indignation somewhat of a desire that it
should be punished right why
because we want to set things right
anger helps us according to Butler to
actually do that he calls it resentment
against Vice and wickedness right and he
tells us that this is actually something
that preserves the common bonds of human
society it holds Human Society together
if we didn't punish people or we didn't
react against people doing the wrong
things and we're like uh hey do whatever
you want to people I don't care even if
it comes from you know your sadistic
urges or your desire to humiliate or you
know whatever is whatever floats your
boat man that would break down Society
according to Butler so he says that it's
a fellow feeling which each individual
has in behalf of the whole species we
get angry when we see wrong things being
done not just to ourselves but to other
people or perhaps even animals right
so you know he says it does not appear
that this generally speaking is that is
at all too high amongst mankind
um you know not everybody does this but
enough people do it and he tells us that
the the point of this is actually to
prevent or remedies
injuries now the way when when Butler
uses the word injury he has in mind not
just hurting another person but doing so
in a way that stems from say malice or
ill will or some sort of desire to hurt
that person it could be from Vice it
could be from wickedness it could be
from all sorts of things we attribute a
bad motive to the person who's doing it
and then we call it according to him an
injury now we often talk about injuries
just as harm or hurts but he has
something different in mind so
deliberate anger is to prevent or remedy
injuries and the as he calls them
miseries arising from these injuries
right so he says this is the end for
which this passion was implanted in US
human beings why did God give us this so
that we could take our part in the the
whole universe in preventing and
remedying or punishing at least the
injuries that other people are doing
either to us or to other people now he
does have a very interesting discussion
here about compassion and he says
um
you know shouldn't we be compassionate
or benevolent to other people this goes
directly to this problem it seems like
there's a conflict here and he says well
I mean you should in general be
compassionate and benevolent to other
people but this needs to be as he says
balanced
by
anger indignation against wickedness
you don't want to be uniformly
benevolent or compassionate because then
you're going to be compassionate or
benevolent to people who really you
shouldn't be collaborating with you
shouldn't be empowering you shouldn't be
signing off on their whatever it is that
they're doing you should be opposing
them instead and so that's what one of
the purposes of anger it helps our good
nature our generally good nature remain
good by opposing evil and he also points
out something else that I think is you
know fairly
you know easy to relate to human beings
are restrained from doing the evil that
they otherwise might do why by fear of
angering others and what that anger
would lead to so it you know this is
another good
outcome of people getting angry you know
you you as a kid you do something mean
to your sibling or a classmate and then
an adult gets angry at you and raises
their voice or maybe you know even
administers corporal punishment you're
like I don't want any more of that I'm
not going to do that sort of thing
anymore well that leads to a better
General benevolence so we can ask
ourselves this question then all right
God perfectly good uh all-powerful made
the universe made us human beings wants
us to be benevolent
did God do right in giving us this
passion of anger and he says we should
learn to be cautious lest we charge God
foolishly by ascribing that to him or
the nature he's given us which is wholly
owing to our own abuse of it so if we
want to complain about people going too
far with anger or anything like that
that's not attributable to God God gave
us a emotion which we could use
perfectly fine for doing all these good
things and instead we human beings come
along and we screw it up in a variety of
ways you know these are what Butler
enumerates as the abuses of anger so he
says men may speak of the degeneracy and
Corruption of the world according to the
experience they've had of it but human
nature considered as the Divine
workmanship should I think be treated as
sacred for in the image of God made he a
man that passion from whence people take
occasion to run into the Dreadful vices
of malice and revenge even that passion
as implanted in our Nature by God is Not
only innocent without you know blame but
notice what else he says here
but of a but also a generous movement of
mind so it goes beyond being not bad not
you know morally culpable it's actually
something good it's generous it gets us
to do some of the things for other
people maybe even for ourselves that we
ought to do in resisting wickedness Vice
evil however you want to put it bad
motives malice perhaps even the Revenge
of other people and uh so this you know
according to Butler basically not only
gets God off the hook but says
you you know not only should you not
blame God you should now have a deeper
appreciation for this
emotion that God implanted within us and
it's usefulness